I become aware of over the last five
years or so that there's a significant
overlap between the concepts that I'm
telling you about and Heidi groups work.
I didn't know that,
you know,
ideas come from lots of different
places.
It's hard to track them down,
but when heidegger was trying to what
what heidegger's philosophical program
essentially consisted of was the
rediscovery of being now he believed
that prior to the ancient Greeks for
quite rational and modern in their
approach to the world that people lived
in a relationship with being that was
much less mediated by interpretive
structures I suppose is one way of
thinking about it and he thought of
being as something that was in framed
and the framing,
which is also a term that I use.
The framing restricts the manner in
which being is able to manifest itself.
So it's like a reduction of being
something specific.
Now it's pretty obvious and Heidi girl
obviously knew this,
that in order to interact with something
you have to simultaneously not interact
with everything.
So you have to reduce the phenomenon to
pinpoint before you can.
You can actually interact with it in any
immediately useful manner,
but when I'm hiding her points was that
that also restricts our ability to be in
direct contact with speeding and he
thought of that as like the ground of
meaning.
Now I think there's different sorts of
meeting and perhaps if you're getting to
is the meaning of the thing that reveals
itself to you.
And so that would be the meaning of an
anomaly in some sense.
And then there's the meaning of the
framework that you used to interpret the
situation.
And then there's the meaning that you
experienced when you transform the
framework that you use to look at
things.
So those are all forms of meeting and
they're all interrelated.
But,
um,
it has striking to me,
Heidi,
that Heidegger,
heidegger hiding Heideggerian approach
to this because in some sense he was
also reacted to niches,
ideas about the debt gone.
So it was an attempt to help people
reorient themselves in the world in,
in the novel historical situation where
we had to become.
You cashed in some ways from our
traditional religious beliefs,
which were in some sense a form of
framing.
You know,
one of the things young said about
religions,
he said the purpose of her religion was
to stop you from having religious
experiences.
It's quite an interesting way of
thinking about it because what was
claiming was that the purpose of a
religious system wants to filter the
overwhelming power of being down to a
point where you could tolerate
conceptualizing it,
but you know the price you paid for.
That was a certain kind of arbitrary
limitation clause.
You're always paying the price for
arbitrators invitation,
but it would be nice if you could also
transcended that from time to time and
realize that there's meaning outside of
the frameworks that you
generally in habit and that you can
narrow those frameworks so much that you
don't get any of the vivifying form of
meaning.
Yeah.
You would think of that when he was
thinking about it symbolically.
You would think about that as the
absence of the water of life sounds,
which is a very.
It's a very calm with multisig
fairytales.
You know the king is old and desperate
guy and the only thing that'll save the
water of life is great.
Him,
his brother fairy tale just call the
water of life.
It has exactly the perfect ms dot
structure.
Now I think I showed you guys this last
time.
Is that correct?
Is the director,
is that okay?
So that kind of summed up our discussion
about the dragon of chaos.
What I was trying to trying to
communicate,
which I think is a very,
very difficult thing is that there are
many different ways of conceptualizing
the ground of being and you can do it
from an objective perspective but.
And that's a very useful tool,
but I think that is a form of framing.
It's not so much a description of the
nature of being per se and the being
that we were speaking of.
I think his property conceptualized at
least at least for some purposes in
relationship to this diagram which says,
well,
being as a field of information from
which you derive the common objects and
entities that you interact with,
but also from which you derive your own
structure,
your own experience and your own
mechanisms of framing and so you can
think of reality as that which allows
for the derivation of those two things
and I also made the case to you that I
think you could make a strong case that
that's actually how your brain works.
Your brain acts like that's the way the
world is,
and then a secondary case that if that's
how your brain acts and your regard
waiting,
then you're faced with a problem.
If you are attempting to make the claim
that the objective world is the ultimate
reality because that isn't how your
brain is set up.
At least in principle,
it evolved so that you wouldn't die
because of your foolish ideas,
embodied or otherwise.
Anyways,
you can wrestle through that and your
own lines.
It's very difficult thing to
conceptualize.
Now,
one of the things that's characteristic
of this particular diaper,
I missed that.
You've seen this in the book.
This is a bit of an elaboration of the
idea of what happens to you when you
encounter a.
normally what happens is fundamentally
that your body prepares to do all
manners of things.
Some of those are negative,
right?
Their experience as negative emotion is
they're fundamentally intensive
protection and protect them so they can
evolve.
They can involve pain and frustration
and disappointment and shame and guilt
and all of those sorts of things as well
as fear.
But then the other side of that as well,
you know there's there's riches to be
had when you encounter something novel
and so the parts of your mind that are
associated with creative exploration and
the reconfiguring of ideas should also
be put on alert and that is what seems
to happen.
So basically your response to a novel,
these to compare to do everything and
that's.
That can be very exciting.
It can be extremely compelling.
So one of the things that I think is
really worth thinking about,
and this is something we'll cover a lot
of the class comes to a halt because
this is one of the only optimistic ideas
I've never been able to derive from
psychology that I actually think might
be true.
And it's a really optimistic idea.
Like if you accept the idea that it's
reasonable to construe the ground of
reality in this manner.
And then you take seriously the two
things,
the fact of your motivational.
You're embodied motivational and
emotional response as one thing and then
the fact of the hierarchy of the
normally so that some things are
anomalous,
you know,
and it kind of trivial manner.
And then some things are a novelist and
an absolutely terrifying manner.
But so if you accept that you can draw
further inference,
which is the well maybe sometimes things
are anomalous in an optimal manner now.
And then I would say,
well,
what we're defined that optimality.
Well let's assume that there is a
meaningful ground of reality.
And then let's assume that there's a
framing system that you have to use to
deal with that.
And that's partly biological,
but it's also partly a consequence of
inculturation,
and then let's assume that that framing
system can get outdated,
so that's all associated with the
stories that we've been talking about so
far.
So then let's assume that the fact that
it can be outdated is also an exit
existential problems,
so it's a constant problem so that not
only do you need to have a framing
system,
but you need to have a mechanism that
you could engage in to update the
framing system optimally and then we can
take that one step further and say,
that's built right into you.
It's part of your nature is part of your
biology,
is part of the structure of your
consciousness.
And then we could say,
well,
here's the hypothesis.
What if that's what's happening?
When you get engaged with something,
so imagine what your brain is trying to
do.
Roughly speaking,
is to situate you in relationship to
being so that you can both tolerate it.
For you can.
You can tolerate it,
appreciate it,
frame it and stay on profit and that
your mind has to be able to signal to
you when you're doing that,
and I think that's what happens when
you're captured by something and you get
engagement.
It is what's happening is your mind is
telling you,
your experiences telling you you're
exactly situated in the right place.
You're stable enough so you're not going
to fall apart,
but you're fluid enough so that you're
not going to fall prey to excess
stability and then the experience of
that as a spirit and experience of
engaged meaning,
but there are phenomena that are
associated with that too.
Like it's easy to pay attention.
It's just straightforward.
It's easy to pay attention to things
that you're engaged by and I think that
that's because your your mind roughly
speaking,
your brain knows that,
that that information flow is maximized
there so you're not going to be
terrified and you're not going to be
bored.
You're gonna be engaged.
You don't fall apart and you stay
updated,
and so the way you experienced that is
that the meeting is optimized under
those conditions.
You're,
you're,
you're deep into the material,
so to speak,
and it's meaningful.
It's directly meaningful.
Yes.
So will this be a framework to explain
why say novel music or stories or like
an grossing video game even would induce
that?
Sure.
No one's another world,
so you're safe,
but also it's like an unfolding
experience with both of those at the
same time because it's,
you don't want to play a video game
where there are no rules and you don't
want to play a video game where the
rules transformed so rapidly and
radically that there's no can model.
You want to play a video game where you
can suspend disbelief.
You know,
there's some play with the axiom,
so maybe there's some things about the
model of reality that aren't exactly
like real reality,
but once that framework is established,
once the rule governed framework is
established,
there's play inside of it.
And that's very embarrassing.
And I think part of the reason it's
engrossing is one,
you actually learn things from playing
games because in some sense you're
always playing a game,
right?
Because you're always inside a reality
that's bounded by a certain set of
assumptions and it's not the total
reality.
It's like a game like representation of
the total reality and you know,
hopefully it's a good enough gain.
Light Representation.
You know,
one of the things I was thinking about
in relationship to video games was no,
I've read critiques of Video Games where
people complain about young people
generally being engaged in video games
to the expense,
having a real life.
And then I was making,
I don't know if you know about Edward,
I think his name is Ed Edward Castronova
now he's an economist who studied video
games and he did this quite awhile ago.
I think it's gotta be more than 10 years
ago now,
but he made the claim at that point that
one of the big massive online player
games,
I think it was world of warcraft,
but that might be wrong,
was like the 20th largest economy in the
world.
Really.
Not In any fate way,
partly because you could sell artifacts
that you were producing on Ebay,
for example,
but also partly because people traded
within it and like there was no reason
to assume that the additional level of
abstraction that that video game
represented was necessarily any more
abstract than what we were already doing
and economies.
So then you could ask yourself,
for example,
think about this.
Is it more real to lead a band of
adventurers through a complex
mythological reality in an online game
or to work at Mcdonald's?
Now you'd say,
well,
what board Mcdonald's?
Because that's real,
but let's,
let's think about that for a minute.
So exactly why is it real mean,
first of all,
but is good and exist unless it was
nested in a whole bunch of other things.
Right?
So it has to be nested in a functional
capitalist economy and that has to be
nested inside a functional political
system.
And then there's all sorts of other
preconditions in terms of material
supply and so forth that have to be in
place before you,
before you're able to work there and
receive tokens for your labor.
Okay,
so
the same thing applies to the video
games and you might say,
well how do you determine which of those
is real?
And I would say,
well maybe one of the ways of
determining whether a game is real is to
what degree do you practice a wide range
of the sub sets of skills that would be
transferable to other beings while
you're playing that game.
And I think you could make a case that
if you're playing a very complex video
game that the activities that you're
engaging in which involve leadership and
cooperation and communication and
problem solving are actually a more
comprehensive subset of the skills that
you would have to develop to work in the
world as a complex place.
Then what you would pick up at
Mcdonald's.
Now you know,
obviously you can argue that,
but it's not self evident.
So,
so back to framing.
Well you know,
one of the things,
the video game,
one of the,
one of the types of meeting,
one of the things that the video game
designers really trying to do is put you
in the zone of proximal.
Now that's a term from the Godspeed who
was a Russian development psychologist
who was probably the most influential
developmental psychologist apart from
Psj.
Now what the Gonski noticed was that
when parents talk to their children,
they talk to them constantly at a level
that slightly exceeded what brand and
you think that's so cool because on one
hand they're communicating with their
children because the children can
understand what they're saying,
but on the other hand there are teaching
them to communicate,
to understand more things at the same
time.
They're doing that in exactly the same
time and he thought about is the zone of
proximal development because it was sort
of dragging the kids pass their current
state of of comprehension and
understanding it and framing into the
next set.
And it's sort of analogous to the
principle that I mentioned to you
earlier about playing a game in a manner
that not only helps you win that game
but helps you when all the other games
that you're going to play after you
played that game.
And that's playing the game at the zone
of proximal development.
Because it involves generalization and I
would say that,
you know,
one of the real debates in psychology,
and it's an appalling debate as far as
I'm concerned,
is what's,
what is it that you can buck used to
buttress yourself against the undeniable
catastrophes of existence,
you know,
because it's obvious to everyone that
existence is tragic and it's fundamental
essence,
right?
Because people are limited and fraud and
mortal.
It's like that's a big problem.
Now,
hypothetically,
that was addressed quite well by
traditional religious structures,
but then our ability to assume that they
were reasonable ways of framing
existence has been badly damaged or
called into question by the rise of
scientific and materialistic and object
to thinking.
So the psychological,
like the,
the,
the academic psychological response to
that has been in many ways that,
well,
you're in framing only shields yourself
shields you from the tragedy of being.
And that's what it is.
It's a defense mechanism and that's the
terror management guys.
It's right.
Fundamentally,
your basic problem is that you're
terrified of dying.
There's no other bloody thing that can
be done about that.
So you have to,
you know,
put up shields of various sorts so that
you're not constantly assaulted by that
problem as you go through your life.
And it's a variant of Freudian theory.
So that's one theory.
And then there's a very,
a theory which is positive illusions,
you know,
which is the idea that it's closely
related is that you can just delude
yourself in an optimal way above the
structure of being so that you can
pretend that things are going to work
out better for you than they probably
are.
And then you don't have to be worried
about the fact that it's tragic because
you just concentrate on your
simplistical optimistic,
you know,
illusions.
It's like no dozer am guessable theories
because they basically say that if you
wait,
woke up and opened your eyes,
what you see would be so terrible that
you would die,
you know,
or that you would want to die,
that it would drive you to suicide.
You know,
that's a,
you gotta be careful before you tell
people that that sort of thing is true
because you're undermining their
capacity to live a genuine existence.
And you're also saying,
well,
you can't live a genuine existed because
the weight of it would be so heavy that
it would.
It would destroy you,
or it will drive you into a position
where you want it to be destroyed.
It's like,
well,
before we get so damn pessimistic about
it,
we might start thinking about whether
there are other phenomena that aren't
illusory or delusional or defense
mechanisms that actually are
characterized by meaning.
And so one of the things I suggested to
you at the beginning of class this class
was that you watched what you said to
find out if what you said was making you
stronger or weaker and that you can
actually feel that.
That's kind of a Rogerian idea because
rogers would say that if what you're
saying wasn't insane with your body
being roughly speaking is Rogers was
really gonna body theorists.
That you would feel that as a kind of
discordance and then that weaken you.
And so it's a much.
It's a much older and deeper idea than
that,
but Roger's articulated very well.
Well,
there's another.
There's another experiment that you can
run that's also very much worth
attending do,
which is watch and see what's
meaningful.
Don't think about it.
Just notice,
notice when you're engaged in something
enough so that the fact of you doing it
is sufficient for the tax,
you know,
because you could say so thankful they
come club this way.
Okay,
well you're a bounded creature and so
you're.
You're beset on all sides by tragedy and
limitation.
You know now that might be necessary
there.
There may be a reason why that's the
case,
but we won't bother with that at the
moment.
We'll talk about that later.
The question then is,
are there conditions under which you
would regard that as acceptable and
answer isn't what people think about.
That's the wrong answer.
The right answer is all.
Pay attention and notice if there are
times like that,
and I think that's the.
That's horace,
that noticing,
that's the eye.
It's not thinking because it's not the
framing process.
It's something outside of that.
It's something that's watching and I
think if you notice,
you'll see if you go through your week,
you'll notice if you have to sort of
stand outside yourself and think,
ha,
I was really into that.
I was pulled right inside it and then
you see phenomenon that occur along with
that which chip and the hiatus detailed
reasonably in his,
in his work on flow.
You don't notice the passing of.
You're not self conscious and the
activity is sustaining.
You experienced it as sustain even
though it might be difficult,
you know,
so it's not a matter of just take easy
way out doing something fun.
It's not that at all.
It can be that it's often you feel that
way when you're doing something that's
exceptionally challenging and difficult
and usually I think it's those things
that are they're real in relationship to
your goal hierarchy,
you know,
so they're,
they're moving you forward in the way
that you've determined that moving
forward is appropriate in so far as
you've sorted that out.
So you know a implies B and B in place.
See it,
see implies d and so forth and you've
sorted that all out,
you know,
so maybe you're working on an essay in
the class that you find meaningful
because you want to derive something
useful from your education so that
you're a good citizen so that you can
live a proper life,
you know,
and so the chaining of all those things
makes the local activity quite richly
meaningful because it's properly
contextualized.
But then there's the other element which
is when you're pushing yourself beyond
that,
not only do you experience the meaning
of what you're doing in relationship to
your goal hierarchy,
you also transcend the goal hierarchy at
the same time so that while you're
working towards realizing it,
you're also working towards transforming
it and improving it all at the same
time.
And I think that you're set up to
experience that as as the highest form
of being.
And then there's a corollary to that,
which is maybe if you spent the bulk of
your time doing that,
you know,
so you've got practice data to you were
doing it.
Maybe you're doing,
I don't know,
you could figure it out for yourself,
but my suspicions are that for many of
you,
that's probably five percent of your
weekly life.
Maybe I'm wrong about that because it's
been a long time since I was your age.
I can't remember what it was like
reading,
you know,
but I do know when I survey
undergraduates and I asked them how much
time they waste,
you know,
they're telling me generally speaking,
it's four to six hours a day and I
actually think it's probably more than
that.
And so that's time not spent in this
particular state of mind and it's wasted
time while you even recognize it as
wasted time because when someone asks
you if it's wasted time,
you say yes and it's like,
well wasted.
It's wasted and you know it.
You're obviously comparing that to some
other sort of time that isn't wasted.
Right?
That you regard as valuable and
meaningful and worth engaging and even
though it might be difficult and require
discipline and all those sorts of
things.
So you might ask yourself,
you know,
if you have times during the week where
you were engaged in often what you're
doing so that you find that
intrinsically meaningful and it removes
the burden of tragedy,
and I don't mean because you're
preoccupied,
I mean because you're experiencing what
you're doing as intrinsically worth the
price.
That's a different thing.
You might think,
okay,
well what if you were in that of mind 80
percent,
85 percent of the time or 90 percent of
the time,
you know,
and that requires a tremendous amount of
discipline and organization and clarity
of purpose and it also requires a
tremendous amount with the truth because
the enemy of setting yourself up so that
you can do that is untruth.
Because what happens is to the degree
that you engage in on the truth,
you,
you contaminate your frames
fundamentally and then you're in real
trouble because you won't be oriented
properly if you're afraid to
contaminated.
They're contaminated to the degree that
you build them out of nonsense in and
delusion.
So yes,
absolutely agree with that.
And probably a natural state,
natural approaches.
The reciprocal.
No,
I think it's natural to be a chimpanzee
is sitting in the jungle spending eight
hours a day eating leaves because you
know,
you're not smart enough to do any better
than that,
you know,
you know what I mean?
So,
so naturals.
The tough,
a tough conception.
Like I said,
I like restaurant.
I mean you could argue that,
oh absolutely.
You know,
sometimes you have fall asleep and
sometimes the right thing to do is to
have leisure time.
But I can tell you,
you know,
I know this from my own experience that
an hour of actual leisure time beats a
month of undeserved holiday.
And so I would say,
well,
what constitutes,
you know,
actual leisure time.
It's like you don't have anything that
you shouldn't be doing at that moment.
That's more important than having a
break.
And if there's nothing about that,
that self deceptive,
you know,
like you're on trying to escape from
your responsibilities by watching a
youtube video about joggers falling on
the ice or something like that,
which apparently is quite a popular one
at the moment.
So you know when you know perfectly well
that when you spend time like that,
especially if you're avoiding doing
something that you've known that you
should be doing using your own standards
of judgment,
that all it does is make you sick.
You know,
like there's a,
there's a physical revulsion that goes
along with that.
And I think what,
what that is,
is your body telling you that you're
contaminating your being by engaging in
such low quality activity,
especially when there's something else
that you know you should be doing.
And that's not restful.
I think that's extremely stressful
because what happens is you basically
tear yourself in to and why does it
tyrant say you're useless?
And the other is like a critical notes
off.
Say I can't help it,
you know,
when it's a terrible state of being to
be in because you're a slave at the same
time and it's very,
very stressful.
It's not restful.
So you're talking to you.
It's like you're describing students how
to take a break and watch the show for
the whole time.
Like going,
Gosh,
as you're constantly like,
you know,
and I think it takes real practice over
years,
you know,
in part of what you'll be reading about
in the book is the necessity of adopting
an apprenticeship,
you know,
because you have to focus yourself in on
something and really you have to focus
in heart and you have to do it for quite
a long time before you have or yourself
into a good enough shape so that you can
even start telling the difference
between reasonable use of leisure time
and pathological time wasting,
which are by no means the same thing.
And it's hard to get it right.
It's very hard to get it right.
I think you have to attend a lot
internal cubes,
you know,
so if you're sitting in front of the
screen and you're feeling somewhat
uneasy,
if disgusted by yourself,
then you have to think,
okay,
just exactly what's going on here.
Am I being too hard on myself?
I actually need a break and I won't
allow that because I'm a tyrant and so
I'm sneaking one even though I'm tired
and should ever break.
That's hard to get because then that
would be an attitude issue,
right?
Are you have you conceptualize the
necessity for leisure property and then
the other possibility is while you're
just being useless and you know it,
you know,
and,
and then that shouldn't be happening.
Something else should be happy,
but it's by no means a straight forward
thing to get those things right.
It's hard.
Now I have a hint about that,
you know,
because I've worked with lots of people
who they're not wasting time,
like they're not wasting five minutes
and sometimes because of the demand,
like usually because the demands on
them,
they put themselves in a position where
the demands on them are so high that if
they waste anytime they will fail.
And so a typical person like that,
a lot of you are going to end up in
those situations if you're lucky.
You know?
So a technical person like that as a
challenging job.
So it's a complex job.
They have to manipulate a lot of
variables constantly.
They have to be attentive and alert,
focused and conscientious.
And they have to do that for long
periods of time,
like well up,
depends on the level of attainment
you're after,
but if you want to attain at the peak of
your chosen discipline,
it's 60 to 80 hours a week and it's,
those are concentrated,
useful hours.
Now some are more useful than others
because you're going to get tired,
but that's what you're aiming at.
And then you know,
well,
do you want to have kids?
That's a big issue too.
And if you want to do both of those,
it's like you don't get,
you don't have kind of wakes,
you don't have any time to waste,
you know?
And so then you have to get hyper
efficient and then you have to ask
yourself,
yeah,
but how much work should I do know
what's the limit should like,
you know,
where is the right limit?
Well the answer to that is quite
straightforward.
You can't work any harder than you can
sustain across weeks,
months and years.
You know.
So some of the people that I've
counseled who are hyper efficient,
one of the holes like fall into is they
worked so hard.
They start getting inefficient and part
of that is they're not paying attention
to their family to guilty about their
children.
Maybe their relationship is becoming
unstable and that's going to cost them
time.
Then like once you're married,
if you let that go and you get into a
divorce battle and it's a custody
battle,
you are screwed.
So like you have to really watch that
and make sure it doesn't happen because
it's like a major illness to have that
happen.
It's not good and you know,
you never really recovered from it in
some sense because you end up with a
fractured,
you know,
you're close,
intimate relationships are fractured and
very difficult thing to do.
So up you're much more likely to get
divorced in your second marriage than
you were in your first.
So it would be like you could hop out of
one into a solution,
you know,
and then also people tired themselves
out,
you know,
so often with the more hyper efficient
people and often a lot of these people
were women and I think the reason for
that is,
you know,
once they have kids in particular,
they're really torn between two sets of
fundamental obligations,
especially for the first three years of
the kid's life,
you know.
And so it's really hard for them to get
the balance rate at to figure out what
that balance is.
But one rule is you got to treat
yourself well enough so you can iterate
your activities.
If you can be playing a degenerating
game and it's a variant of the pig and
the idea of the calibrating state,
right?
And it could have a great state will
maintain itself and that can be within
you or can be within a group of people
or it can be either in you or within a
group of people across a long span of
time.
And that's really well equilibrate.
So a lot of the people that I dealt with
who were working themselves too hard,
we figured out ways they can take
vacations.
They couldn't usually decreased the
number of hours per week or per week
wasn't possible.
Just the demands of the job,
like in the law firm or something like
that.
You know,
you might think what Cathy,
just lighten up.
The answer to that is you don't get paid
$750 an hour for lightening up.
It's like you're on call right now
whenever your client wants you and the
answer isn't,
well,
you know,
I need to take a break.
Like then.
Then you don't get the pay because
that's what they're paying is for.
But one of the things I noticed quite
quickly was the people scheduled their
time so they took more vacations.
The number of hours they can work
productively actually went up,
not down.
So you can get the balance right,
but it's not.
It's not a simple thing to do,
but so isn't that.
You're only going to find engagement in
sheer physical productive activity.
There's lots of places where you can be
engaged,
you can be engaged in art,
you can be engaged in literature,
you've been engaged in relationships.
You can be engaged in your children like
there's no shortage of places of
meaning,
but you have to interact with those
places of meeting property and you have
to organize the multiple places where
you derive meaning in a manner that's
sustaining to all of them and that's
what you've got your grain right,
but getting your frame rate isn't enough
because you have to get your frame right
in a way that allows you to update your
frame as you continue moving forward
with it.
And I do believe because I do believe
that the world that were adapted to as
biological organisms is the world where
reality is information.
I believe that when when your nervous
system signals to you that all is well,
all is well.
It's true.
You're in the right place at the right
time.
You're bearing exactly the right amount
of load and the right amount of load is
enough to keep you talked and ready and
improve,
and when you slip into that slot,
I think all of the existential problems
that that,
that,
that arise to push people towards
nihilism and hopelessness or or
sometimes towards totalitarianism,
totalitarianism,
that rigidity,
that problem just goes away and it's
because you solve it.
It's not because it's not a problem,
it's a bloody problem,
but that doesn't mean that you know,
because one of the things that monitor
people do is they conceptualize
themselves as the defeated aim priority.
You know that the fact that life is
tragic and that you're not all you could
be in,
that everything will come to an end
means that you're not.
By definition,
you're not up to the task.
It's like that's by no means obvious
man.
People are tough,
like they're so tough.
It's unbelievable.
Why don't you know you see that on
Youtube with you?
Because I don't want to look at Youtube
now.
Now you can feel terrible above it.
One of the things I do like looking at
it or the extreme sports that people
engage in,
you know,
and I mean people can do unbelievable
things.
They're completely,
they're completely off their rocker,
know they can do things with their
bodies that you just can't possibly
imagine.
I was looking for example at there was a
video that went around the wild ago
about it was a video tape of the woman
who won the 1956 I'm hurdling know we
bounce off of one of those horses for
gymnastics and so she did.
Her routine was videotaped and then the
next video tape was over.
The person who won the gold in the
Olympics at the last Olympics and it was
like the first woman did this really
cool role,
often fall off the horse.
It was quite spectacular.
It's like the second one was like 20
feet in the air with for flipped end
over end,
you know,
vertically.
If they wasn't my favorite night and
they weren't even the same creatures,
why don't look like some kind of kind of
like android kangaroo and the other
book,
like a pretty competent gym teacher.
So you know,
I mean God only knows what the limits of
human ability are,
but we certainly haven't touched them.
And you guys,
most of you have no idea what you're
capable of if you like,
if you really got your acts together
when you were a force,
because another thing you might think
about is maybe the existential misery
that you experienced in your life is
directly proportional to the amount of
time you waste.
Because if,
if the dragon gardens a treasure,
you know,
and your job is to get the damn treasure
and you need it,
you need it.
It's not,
it's not optional without the treasury.
You don't have the riches necessary to
live all the time.
You're wasting his time that you're not
spent in the treasure room
fundamentally.
And so,
you know,
if you're not spending all your time in
the treasurer room,
you can't complain about being poor.
So it's a good thing to think about,
you know,
because it's,
and this is what makes it optimistic.
It's possible that if you utilize what
was in front of you,
and so that will be the ground of being.
Let's say if you utilize that,
that would be enough,
or maybe you could get even really lucky
and if you utilize it properly,
it wouldn't just be enough.
That would be more than enough,
you know,
so you could go from say,
well,
it's okay to be a limited and mortal
being too saying,
hey,
this is a pretty damn good deal and if I
could,
I'd sign on for it again.
That was actually niches,
idea of the eternal return,
you know,
so when he was trying to figure out what
people should do as a consequence of the
collapse of the ethical system,
it constituted classical religious
belief.
He conjured up the idea of eternal
return.
It was roughly this,
you should live in such a way so that if
you had to repeat what you were doing
forever into infinity,
you would say yes to that.
And that's an,
that's an idea like the state,
except obviously it's stretched into
huge expanses of time.
You know,
that's a high level thing to a map.
But you know,
so here's,
here's another example.
Like I've seen people who,
who get stuck in,
in very bureaucratic organizations,
you know,
and they just get bloody well tortured
by death because it's mindless tyranny,
stupid rules and and on arbitrary
decisions and counterproductive
management advice and jealousy and
punishment for doing well and you know,
everything you can do to possibly set up
a situation where the person who's got
the jaw is just crushed by it,
that people won't say anything.
It's,
well,
what would happen if you said something
like,
why do you want me to do this?
It looks stupid.
And they might be thinking,
Oh God,
I couldn't have thought it was stupid
to,
you know,
but someone else told me to do it.
Highly probable that they would be
thinking that.
It's like,
what happens if you just refused to do
stupid,
useless meetings,
meaningless things.
It's like,
that's a rule.
I don't feel stupid.
Useless for me.
You know,
one of the things that happens in
corporations,
and I've seen this happen many times,
is that the corporation gets.
It's like,
it's like an elephant that gets loaded
with intestinal parasites.
And,
and I mean that.
I mean that as a biological analogy,
I really do,
because a corporation is a body in some
sense.
It has a tremendous amount of building
value and what can happen as the
corporation develops as it gets full of
people who just pull up the value,
they don't actually do anything.
They raped the brand is what they do
because the brand has value.
You know,
like the Disney brand has value because
it's associated with quality,
you know,
and if you want it to destroy that,
you take over the company and you've put
out snow white too and snow white three,
it's like five and snow white 12 until
and everybody would buy it until like
snow white 20 when they would trust you
anymore.
And then you've sucked all the value out
of the company and its death,
you know,
or you get people who come into the
corporation and all they want to do is
maneuver up to the talk.
They don't give a damn about what the
thing is supposed to be producing or
about how they're structuring their
relationships with other people or about
anything that has to do with the truth.
They use language instrumental to reach
their goals and you get people like
that,
your company and it's like it's dead.
It's gone.
And that happens to companies all the
time because they don't last.
Right?
This is why Marx was wrong.
You know,
he said power and money accumulate in
the hands of fewer and fewer people.
What he didn't say is it's always
different.
People,
you know,
it's like there's a one percent,
but it's not the same people.
You know,
most family fortunes don't last three
generations and neither do most large
companies.
So there's a lot of dynamic turnover,
but you know,
you guys are going to be working in
companies.
The Lord have you at at least at some
point it pretty damn significant levels
and even at an entry level,
you have more power than you think.
You know,
it is not necessary to do things you
know are stupid and meaningless.
And if you're,
if,
if the situation that you're in is
demanding that,
then you might ask yourself,
hmm,
maybe I should be somewhere else.
And then you might say,
well,
I can't be.
What I would say to that is prepared to
yourself to be like,
if you're going to go into a company and
you want to live ethically,
you need an escape strategy and you need
to have that along with you all the
time,
so you need an updated resume and it
need to be keeping your damn on,
on the job market so that you can see
where the other opportunities along live
for you and so you're not afraid to
pursue them.
You know,
so you got to hold your interview
skills.
You've got to keep your damn resume on a
shot.
You've got to make sure you have a broad
social network and you have to do it
consciously.
And so even if some Dane back tells you
to do stump to something
counterproductive,
meaningless,
and we'll push it one step farther than
clearly unethical,
you can say no and you can meet it
because no means I'm not doing that.
And if you push me,
we'll either have a war or I'll go
somewhere else.
It's like,
that's what no means.
That that's what it means.
It means I'm not doing this and you
can't say no till you haven't an
alternative,
right?
You have to set yourself up so that no
doesn't kill you because obviously then
you won't say it needed.
These are important things to consider
because the actions that you take up,
the level of your individual career are
going to have far more impact on the
ethics and the productivity of the place
that you worked and then you can imagine
especially if you're someone who's
straight and sees what's right in front
of their face because those are the
people that keep the data companies
running and there's not necessarily that
many of them know the prices.
Law Rule is that square root of the
number of people who are doing your job
do half the work.
So you could say that in a company of a
thousand people,
30 people are doing half the work.
You know when you could be one of them
and then if you are one,
except you can bloody well say no
because they actually need you and so
your last would be can be a catastrophe
and that's what you want to aim for.
It's like you want to be the person
who's lost would be a catastrophe
because then you've got some power and
then you can bargain and then you don't
have to do a stupid,
useless crooked things and you'll have a
much better life if you don't have to do
those things.
So very,
very practical advice.
So when you were talking about how like
divorce and like if you have a family
and you have like a divorced people
sometimes never thought into that and I
remember you saying that it is locked
before too.
So what do you think about that?
It's so horrible and what am I people to
come?
Okay,
well let's think about this for a minute
then what?
We'll go back to the symbolic stuff.
How many chances do you think you'll
have in your life for it?
For like a serious high quality intimate
relationship?
What do you guys think?
How many chances are you going to have
for that?
Okay,
that's good.
That's good.
I would say probably top out in a boat.
Okay,
so that's not that many chances.
You get old quick.
You know by the time you're 45 you're
not going to have a family and the well
you can do that sometimes if you're male
or female maybe,
but it gets pretty rough and you're
looking probably at that point you had a
fair bit of in vitro and that sort of
interactions top.
It's hard on people so you know,
not only you not have that many chances,
you don't have that much time,
so you're going to get it right.
So if you get it wrong and costs you
like maybe it'll cost you five years,
five years is a long time,
so and three,
five year cost,
you lost things there that you can't
replace.
Okay.
So that's one part of it is you don't
have that many chances and it's costly
to to burn up the time.
Okay.
The second thing is,
okay,
divorce is very complicated,
like it's not so bad if you get divorced
to someone who's reasonable,
but often the reason that you're getting
divorced is that one or the other or
both of you aren't that reasonable and
what that might mean.
You might be negotiating with someone
whose basic goal is to make sure that
you don't have another day of success in
the next 20 years and if that's their
goal,
they will attain it.
So,
and there's lots of ways people do that
and they usually do it by owning the
children hostage.
People will definitely do that.
They do it all the time,
you know,
so you want to avoid that and then you
know,
then of course it's hard on the
relationship you have with your children
and like that's.
Those are probably the most important
relationships you have in your life.
You know,
it's like might be parents,
might be siblings,
might be your partner,
might be your kids.
But I think when it comes right down to
it,
your parents are old and so were you.
When your kids aren't and they're just
as close.
Plus they need you and so will you start
twisting and messing.
Not About,
boy,
it's hard on your psyche.
It's hard on the kids too,
so you know.
So then I'm just thinking about that and
how that's a cost.
If you,
if you mess it up like a five year cost,
they cost you,
right?
Oh,
and it might be a 15 year cost if you
were in a custody battle and cost you a
quarter of a million dollars,
right?
Yeah.
But like is it then would you say like
being a psychologist,
that it's better for people to like
pursue a relationship that's not good
enough to continue to do that and
possibly incur further costs than it is
to just cut it off because it would
divorce.
Okay.
It's a complicated question.
What I would say is don't make the kind
of mistakes that get you into such a
stupid relationship to begin with.
Okay.
Because that's the answer to that
question.
And the way you do that is by trying not
to delude yourself any more than is
absolutely necessary.
And that means when you're in the damn
relationship,
tell the person the truth and trying to
figure out what the truth for you and
don't put up with any nonsense and stand
up for yourself and also aimed towards
the good,
you know,
if you do all those things,
then your relationship is probably going
to work if you're trying to do all those
things really,
and you have a partner that will not do
that,
then leave.
But
it's a rare person who will do that if
they're stepped along the way property
and they learn how to do it.
Now,
not everyone's like that because you do
run into some people who are basically
devoted towards mayhem and trouble,
you know.
But usually you know,
a person is a balance of striving for
the good and you know,
messing about in the health.
And you know,
you're both like that.
When you start a relationship and you
try to tilt it towards the good and then
you will run into that problem.
So.
But you have to do that right from the
beginning of the relationship.
You know,
it doesn't take that much to corrupt a
relationship so that it's not really
salvageable.
It the mistakes.
Three or four acts of infidelity,
your doctor,
you don't get to come back from that
because the fundamental element of trust
is being removed and then you can
communicate with the person because you
don't know if they're telling you the
truth and then you don't know if you're
dealing with reality and if you're not
dealing with reality with your partner,
it's like good luck fixing that.
It's like you're working on a ghost car.
Well the real one is sitting in the shop
with the motor on it.
You know it's not going to get you
anywhere.
So a lot of the issue is don't get into
trouble to begin with.
If you are in the trouble,
well then you try to straighten yourself
out and see if you can fix it.
Well,
if you can't,
your options aren't great and it depends
on the particularities of the situation.
Not Know I have people that I counseled.
It's like leave that person and the role
is they're lying to you.
They aren't aiming up and you won't be
able to tolerate being with them for 10
years without becoming resentful,
alcoholic and homicide,
so that's a bad outcome.
There's nothing you can do to avoid it,
so you might as well leave and.
But you know,
you'd have to have.
That sort of note has to be the truth
because it's no fun.
It's no good to leave someone who's
struggling in an alert.
You know,
when you think,
well,
I'm with this person.
They're not going anywhere.
You know,
maybe they have an alcohol problem and
they're resentful.
It's like,
but I'm all they've got,
well,
they bloody well better want to have to
fix that because you're not going to
deal with fixed.
All that'll happen is you'll end up in
the same place.
Now if they really want to fix more than
anything and they're willing to tell the
truth about it and willing to interact
with you,
then there's a ghost of a chance.
You might pull through it,
but
it's very hard to fix someone and it's
really hard to fix someone who does not
want to be fixed and there's lots of
people like that.
So my
parents divorced,
so,
um,
I know that a lot of failing,
you're marketing the kid if you.
And I've had to deal with a lot of the
tension,
which is like choosing your parents.
But um,
when everyone asks like,
do you like something?
Lawyers?
I'm like,
I,
I see how much they fight now.
And I can't imagine having that happen
like school,
an answer to the question.
It depends on the particular situation.
And so a lot,
there's lots of situations where a
general answer doesn't suffice,
but I would say it is.
This is a tough one.
I can tell you what's happened since the
divorce law.
Scott are liberalized.
The first thing that happens is that all
of you are going to be divorced and
about the same rate as people would have
been two years ago because rich people
still get married and they generally
don't get divorced.
Poor people do not get married and
that's like 60 percent of the population
and it's ramping up quick and there's no
evidence whatsoever that that's anything
but catastrophic.
So kids who are raised by single parents
do not do as well.
Now,
that doesn't mean there aren't some
single parents who are doing a stellar
job,
obviously neurons and there's some
married parents to do a terrible job.
That's not the issue.
The issue is the bulk of the evidence
and the bulk of the evidence strongly
suggests that children who are raised
with two parents do better.
Well,
why?
It's impossible to raise children.
Jesus,
they're expensive,
they're troubleshooting,
they're smart,
and they're useless.
You know,
so,
and you've got them for 20 years.
It's like you're going to do that by
yourself.
Sure.
You are near to be working at a horrible
job.
Forty hours a week or more like a retail
job for example,
where they just treat you like a slave
and then you're going to go home to your
miserable kids because I lost it.
It's like,
that's not fun and you know,
it's increasingly the norm for huge
chunks of our population,
like elitist liberal types,
like all of you,
for example,
don't pay much attention to what happens
to people who were actually core,
but as far as I can tell,
it's been a bloody catastrophe for them.
You know,
there's an old saying when the upper
class gets a cold,
the lower class gets pneumonia and you
know,
the thing about that same.
It's true.
It's like,
it's not a metaphor.
It's literally the case.
If an epidemic sweeps through a Barbie
relation,
the population dies from the poor
people.
Awkward because they're so damn stress.
So,
you know,
I would say with regards to marriage and
I'd been married long time sister both
26 years now and I've noticed a bunch of
things about marriage.
One is two brains are better than one.
So if you communicate with your partner
because they're not like you,
it's like you have a corpus callosum
between you,
you know,
and they'll tell you things you don't
understand.
You know,
like when you're being stupid,
you know,
in a typically feminine way.
Sarah typically masculine way or
whatever,
stupid way you managed to be stupid to
you and that can be really helpful even
though it's extremely annoying,
you know,
and they can help you make decisions and
they're a good place to.
They're good place to confess to,
you know,
and it's really helpful when you're
trying to figure out how to discipline
children so that you're not a pathetic
milk saw who lets them run all over you
or some tire or who you know,
likes to beat them with a stick when
they sneeze,
you know,
hopefully you kind of find some pleasant
middle ground in there and it's a lot
easier to do that with two people in
with one and then they can spell you off
when you're exhausted.
Particularly useful if you have small
children because you will be exhausted
when you have small children,
you know,
plus the narrative of your life as
continuity.
And that's nice.
You know,
and if your home is set up properly,
it's actually a pleasure to go to it.
You know,
it is that it is a buttress against the
chaotic and uncaring external world
because the external world in many ways,
it doesn't give a damn both you,
you know,
so if you go home and it's set up
reasonably well,
it's like,
Hey,
you've got somewhere to belong.
That's not so bad.
Just uh,
another,
um,
related situation that as growth,
personal relevance for other people to
do that,
um,
in,
in many situations like when something
bad happens,
you know,
okay,
yeah,
I've got to do some kind of imperative
thing.
Right.
And uh,
so say it's like a health scare and go,
can I go work on my diet?
And then it's a divorce.
It's like,
all right,
we want to go and work through why I
didn't think I was headed for divorce
for the last 20 years,
but now it just happened.
And,
but,
but in some situations people building
out repair but they don't want to get
them to actually be repairing.
So they go to people who are specialists
in other areas of,
of life,
personal,
psychological dealers and stuff like
that.
Anything but divorce,
like attention deficit work on your
scopes or like work on these,
uh,
or like assertiveness training or
something like that.
But like they're,
they're like,
they're diligently avoiding the heart of
the methods.
And what was your major
and if you were in a family with
somebody like that,
is there something like that?
Well,
you know,
some situations are like Humpty dumpty,
right?
There's no putting it back together now.
But again,
in terms of avoidance of those
situations,
like you think about that hierarchy.
Yeah.
Well divorce is a low resolution,
high impact solution because it just
tears a chunk of that hierarchy out,
throws in the way that's a lot and it's
cost,
it's going to hurt you.
Okay.
So then you think,
well,
what,
what might you do instead of that?
The real answer is solve the damn
problems as they arise.
You know?
And that's hard and it requires drilling
down.
It really requires drilling down.
So one of the things I want to build,
for example,
which I haven't yet,
it's Kinda like going to be like this
future authoring thing that you guys do.
I want to build a problem solving matrix
for,
for compost because like,
because at the end,
here's how not to get divorced from your
wife,
figure out how to set the table
properly.
Now what does that mean?
It's really,
really complicated and it's like,
who's going to cook?
When are they going to cook?
Why are they cooking?
How should you respond to it?
Who buys groceries?
What are the groceries going to be?
Who's going to put them away?
How do you say thanks when someone does
something for you in the domestic
environment and what's happened,
and this is part of the depth of God,
roughly speaking,
is that the roles are gone.
Okay?
And what that means is you better be
awake because it turns out that running
a kitchen in a house is unbelievably
complicated and difficult,
and so you have to negotiate how to do
it and you're a terrible negotiator.
You don't know how to decompose the damn
problem to the point where you could
solve it.
You won't admit what you want.
You won't admit what your life,
you won't pay any attention to what
actually irritates you.
You know,
so you'd like to think that you're nice
and easy to get along with,
but you're not,
you're basically Hitler,
you know,
and so until you realize that you can't
even tell your partner what you want.
And so this is where philosophy hits the
road or hits the ground,
you know,
it's like trying to negotiate,
to stable solution to how you're going
to run the kitchen because that's where
the battle between the sexist,
by the way,
there's two places where it really hits
one who's going to take care of the
little kids to,
to who is going to work in the kitchen
and under what circumstances.
It's like you figure those things out.
You can consider yourself a philosopher,
a very difficult.
And the cost for not doing it is low
quality food in a hostile environment,
bratty children that you hate,
resentment,
hostility,
the accumulation of insults at assaults
and either a divorce or really unhappy
marriage.
So,
but what did.
But just to take it back,
what do you do when somebody has a,
like to use a metaphor like has it
helped care?
And then there was like say the cancer
and then instead of quitting smoking,
they just started taking a multivitamin
in the morning.
It's like,
what do you do if you're watching
somebody treat their smoking with an
antibiotic was a multivitamin rather
than
then you go to war three.
I'm not kidding you tighten them into
doing what you have.
But a war isn't just like you fly into a
rage and you know,
throw dishes,
explaining,
that's not helpful.
No worries.
Okay,
you are not going to smoke anymore.
And so then you think,
okay,
well what do you have to do to do that?
So maybe it's your father,
um,
I'm going to call you everyday and
harass you.
And if that doesn't work then I'm going
to come over and harassed and I'm going
to burn up all your cigarettes.
And then I'm going to get your friends
to come over and tell you that you're a
bloody idiot and I'm going to put
pressure on you.
And your mom's going to help too.
And if you don't quit smoking,
she's going to leave.
It's like it's life or death.
What's it going to be?
Now,
you know,
you may say you don't want to go to war,
you might also say that it's not even
your right to go to war,
but if you're faced with a situation
where it's someone you love is engaging
in a behavior that seriously
counterproductive,
it's like your ratchet up the pressure
until they stop or you can't stand it
anymore and if you can't stand it
anymore,
you lose,
you know,
lots of things are a war and so you and
you have to be prepared for a book like,
because that's also a very,
to begin with to say no,
you know,
videos got offended in a way to take it
back to you.
You're getting is that like you got to
find it in a way that you can continue
to have these battles so that it doesn't
just become a failed enterprise and the
first conversation,
right.
If you can blow apart the whole
relationship,
you know,
and the personal do that to you too.
They'll,
they'll often say,
well,
you can quit,
but if you don't start biting me,
I'm never going to talk to you again.
I'm like,
you can't be afraid of that sort of
thing.
It's like if you can also tell them the
difficult,
that's an inappropriate move.
It's a nuclear bomb.
It's like,
don't bring up the nuclear bombs yet.
Johnson and the will say,
look,
I don't need to get health tips from
you.
I'm the parent.
I'm telling you what's healthy to eat or
whatever.
You shouldn't be able to respond to
that.
That's just a.
that's just an entry level volume that
you're the parents.
Oh,
well,
hey,
that's a brilliant observation.
Would say,
well,
these things,
issues or whatever,
sending my personal romantic sexual life
that like,
I'm not comfortable sharing things with
you,
so yeah.
Well you can tell them that you're not
comfortable living with the consequences
of their stupid decisions and you're
stuck with it too because you know the
personal say,
well,
this is me.
Well,
yeah,
right,
except you're connected to.
He's connected to your mother,
let's say,
and they're both connected to you and
they're all connected to their friends.
It's like,
sorry,
this isn't just about you.
You know,
if you're on an island,
while even then it wouldn't just be
about you,
but it would be more of a use.
So that's just weak argumentation and
what people will do when you're having a
war with them is they'll have like 10 or
11 prepared responses.
They're always cliches,
you know,
and so you just back that way,
they're just cliche.
It's like,
okay,
well first of all we're going to get
through the cliches,
but then what happens?
Then they get math and then they'll
stomp away.
Then they'll cry.
It's like if you can get through all
that,
well then maybe you can have a
discussion,
you know,
and then.
But you got to think it through.
You actually care if you're parked,
if you're a person is smoking themselves
today.
Of course I love it.
It's like,
yeah,
sure you make.
It's like,
why is it important to you?
Why does it work?
Why does it matter?
Why is it worth going to war about it?
And you need to know that you need to
know it and you have to be able to tell.
But first,
you know,
and if you could tell them that if you
could really figure it out and you can
really tell them that there's,
sometimes they'll listen because they
don't,
they don't want to know that they're
tearing you apart,
you know,
and they're going to do everything not
to see that it's my problem.
Yeah,
well I wish it wasn't a problem because
then I wouldn't have to worry about it,
but unfortunately,
you know,
or fortunately we're tied together at
the bottom of the barrel so you know,
we better figure out how to deal with
this.
So it's very hard thing to do and it's
way better to address those things
before they become catastrophic because
by the time they've gotten to the point
where it's a 15 year problems,
it's like Jesus,
you're dealing with a very large tire.
Matt,
at that point,
you know.
So one of the things I really liked
about the Mesopotamian creation myth is
that it tells you what happens if you
muck around,
you know,
it says,
because remember that Mesopotamian gods,
they kill app suit,
right?
That's the structure they all rest on.
So it's just this sort of a hollow steel
shell now and the end now things alive
and being fixed.
No one's paying attention.
What comes,
what happens on the longer that goes on,
the bigger the monster that makes its
appearance,
you know,
and you could easily be in a situation
where the boxster that people are hiding
from his.
So Cam being you may not have the skills
to kill it.
So,
you know,
even remember horace,
when he goes off that off after I'm sad,
he loses an eye.
It's like it's no joke,
you know,
and he's a god and he wins and he still
loses.
Not So,
you know,
with someone who's smoking,
one of the things you may have to
confront is their absolute cynicism
about life.
Seriously thought through.
And there's plenty of reasons to be
cynical about life and resentful and
full of hate and all of those things.
You know,
so,
so you,
the bigger the war that clear the head,
you know,
because you're going to hit,
you're going to find the monsters
underneath the problem.
And they're usually archetypal.
You know,
I've been in lots of situations with my
clients where the only language that
could be used to describe what was going
on was religious because the problems
were so deep,
like there's so good against evil that
there isn't any other language that's
even close to powerful enough,
and that's usually what happens in
households where there's a truly
homicidal battle going on.
Like a deep full problem for example.
And if were you in my personality class,
you watch crumb.
Oh yeah,
that's intense.
If you want to see psychological about
the kind you wouldn't see normally
unless you were a clinician and like a
clinician who was really into the
situation crumbled Kelly.
It's available online.
You probably have to rent,
but it's the pathology and that families
are critical and it's rough.
Oh yeah.
Brilliant documentary.
The guy that made the documentary to the
family.
Yes.
Beforehand.
So they laid a band,
you know,
and they were also nurse assistance.
Yeah.
That's kind of like what a monstrous
animal looks like right away.
Like that.
He had like this,
he had this very large,
like clean mother.
I don't know,
it's was quite the creature.
She was sort of like this monstrous
creature and so all of his restaurants,
we sort of like it and so all of his
drawings were like if these monstrous
like monster swimming with him as a
parasitical appendage.
Right.
That's the Freudian storyboard.
If you don't think that's real,
you haven't looked at any pathological
families because it's re.
Freud's claim was.
That's the first battle that people
fighting.
If you lose,
there's a think about it.
Here's some battles you got to get away
from your mother to get to kindergarten.
Great.
That's about it.
Number one,
and then you've got to make friends
that's bad enough to and then you've got
to get away from your family.
It's like in the eatable situation,
you don't win the first battle,
your screw and it's worse even because
the reason you don't is because there's
something about one or both parents that
is bloody well doing everything it
possibly can to make sure that you don't
and you think,
well,
that's pretty dark.
Who would ever believe that?
But it's like you failed in your life in
a serious way.
You know,
and you're resentful and irritable,
miserable about it.
What makes you think you're going to
facilitate your child's success?
What makes you think you're going to be
able to stand to see someone thrive
where you failed?
It's like,
yeah,
right.
If you were that kind of safe,
you wouldn't have failed to begin with
no one in that particular away.
So you know,
families can be just.
Freud was a smart man and you know,
if you watched chrome,
you can see exactly what he was talking
about.
Some very,
very difficult to get access to that
kind of experience.
Unless you happen to be in that
situation or you know,
you're helping someone cope with it and
you're really tied in.
So.
And that's a perfect segue to the great
mother.
Now.
So the hypothesis here is that,
that,
you know,
what's complex hypothesis,
but the hypothesis fundamentally is that
your basic ways that you break down
being as such,
which I would say is,
is,
is represented symbolically by these
ceramic tile forums that have the
capacity to be spiritual or to be,
to reveal the treasure because you're a
social primate and you sort of a nuclear
family,
social,
primate,
your primary cognitive categories are
male,
female,
I think it's male,
and child,
and the child tends to take on the
aspect of the sun like the male child
for reasons that we'll go into.
But,
um,
and I think it's,
I think it's because of the overwhelming
reality of the feminine throughout
history has been the feminine in
relationship to procreation is the
defining characteristic of the feminine.
And so you can define the feminine with
femininity,
but if you're going to define the child
whose relationship isn't primarily
appropriative known as a child,
you don't use feminine symbolism to do
that.
So it makes it complicated.
It doesn't map.
So here's an example of that.
So there's a um,
you see that sound a herb roast chicken.
This is interesting.
I have one of these up in my office.
Wouldn't any of you guys come up and see
what I found?
One in Mexico or actually someone found
it and I bought it from them.
Maybe not next to,
but whatever.
It's exactly one of these things.
It's so cool,
except it's got legs at the bottom and
it stands out.
It's this,
except it's chicken with a snake wrapped
around its neck.
You know,
Scott,
please wait.
He's off to the side and on each wing is
a spider web,
which I really love.
It's absolutely perfect.
And so it's an archetypal image in the
image of something like you see in the
US too with the snake that the US often
used for.
The Americans often use that flag.
It's like an eagle with a snake and it's
talents.
That's another variant of the same sort
of assembled and it's,
it's this combination of matter and
spirit,
burden,
reptile,
and it does represent the ground of
being all things considered.
And then out of that springs,
these primary phenomenon,
that's father,
mother child,
roughly speaking,
and those correspond to nature,
culture,
roughly speaking,
and the thing that mediates between the
two of them.
And that's the hero.
Now it's not just the hero because it's
also the adversary,
because the adversary is the thing that
refuses to mediate between those two.
And that's just as much part of the
individual as the part that will do it.
Those are logged in internal combat,
so to speak now.
But that's the first differentiation.
And I think the reason for that is that
that is how we differentiate the world
as we sprayed into consciousness and
existence.
It's like,
first of all,
it's a cake.
It's chaos.
It's like formless Keto Os.
That's where you've come from,
whatever that means.
And then post you've got a mother,
that's for sure.
That's a primary reality.
And you have a father and you know,
even if you don't have a father there
because you're a human being,
you have a father because the father is
the patriarchal structure or the
framing.
You know,
it's the,
it's the inculturation.
It's the embodiment of enculturation and
that's going to be in you as you get
inculturated,
but it's distributed everywhere in every
one.
Those are the rules by which people
live.
Not even just the rules,
click the behavioral rituals,
but govern our interactions and if you
don't incorporate,
if you don't become enculturated by the
time you,
for your you're,
you're either new astrophe or you're
antisocial and criminal.
That's the basic rule.
And we know the literature on anti
social behavior.
It's like basically what happens is
there's about 10 percent,
five to 10 percent of boys who are very
aggressive and assertive and selfish,
roughly speaking,
self oriented when they're two and you
can find them,
you just put them together with other
two year olds and there's this subset of
them.
They're almost always boys,
but not always who bite,
kick,
hit and steel.
And they just do that.
And the reason is they're like top
little monsters and you know,
they're out there asserting themselves.
It's just the tail end of a continuum
and it's mostly agreeableness.
They're disagreeable kids,
their toughest boots,
you know,
and they'll basically stand up to you
and they're not that easy to scare,
especially if they're low in
neuroticism.
And so with them it's like,
why the hell should I listen to you?
And my son was like that and he was like
that when he was nine months old,
I,
he'd stare me down like so impressive.
It's really soft and it's like what
makes it so,
so,
so anyways,
it's either with the,
with the kids that are like that.
If you don't socialize them by the time,
therefore they,
they then they can't make friends
because they don't know how to play and
share and all those things.
And then they ended up outcasts and you
know,
puberty hits,
the testosterone rises and Poof,
they're in jail,
you know,
and whatever you go on to be
inculturated.
And that's the incorporation of great
father and some of that's,
that's the Super Ego from the audience
perspective to some of that is positive
because you bloody well better know how
to share play games.
And some of it's negative because one of
the things that's so weird about having
little kids is that you know,
what you give them hell mostly for is
having fun.
It's horrible,
you know,
because you think you're always
punishing kids if we do for breaking
rules.
And so on snow,
that's what you do.
It's like they're running around
screaming at the top with their guns.
They're completely having a blast,
you know,
and they're destroying the house in the
process,
but they're really having fun and you
know,
you're,
you guys settled out right now.
It's like you're doing that all the
time.
So not only do you bring the negative
emotion,
you know,
the tiers and the pavement,
the frustration and the anger and the
hostility under control.
So they stopped having temper tantrums
and they don't hit you when they're mad
or themselves.
But get that all under control.
Jesus regulate the positive promotion.
It just dampened it right down until
they can go sit with their 80 year old
grandmother quietly,
you know.
So it's a real restricting process.
And that's why half of the Greek father
is a tyrant.
There's no way out of that,
you know,
like you hope that the whole damn thing
isn't a tyrant because obviously by
socializing your children,
you're doing them a great favor right
here.
First of all,
they learned how to talk.
That's very useful.
They learn how to read,
they learn how to play with other kids,
so at the same time that you're
constraining the hallow them and making
them less than they were in some ways,
you're also opening up vistas to them
that they would otherwise not have
access to.
You know,
in one of the things that's very bunch
we're thinking about is that you
basically die into your personality.
You know,
so what happens?
It's a Darwinian issue.
Fundamentally.
What are your first board of your
neurons?
Have more connections than you can shake
a stick at like more than you'll ever
have in your entire life.
And then all the ones you don't use dye
and so what that is,
it's a collapse of potential into
actuality.
But let's make no mistake about it.
It's costly because you become what you
are instead of all the things that you
could have been and people experienced
that as a cost.
That's the story of Peter Pan.
I don't want to grow up because I don't
want to become one thing instead of the
many things I could be.
Now,
the problem with that theory is you get
a whole right,
so you don't sustain your potential
without.
Even if you don't develop it,
it doesn't just sit around and go stale.
Curdles get salary,
so it's not an.
It's not an acceptable choice that
people make that choice all the time,
especially if they take the great father
isn't anything but captain right?
A terrible heidrick tyrant who's
terrified of death crocodile with the
clock in its stomach.
It's already got a piece of him and
that's the great.
That's the dragon of chaos.
He's being chased by the dragon of
chaos.
Like if you were terrified of the dragon
of chaos and you're in the patriarchal
role and there'd be a tyrant and then
why the hell would anyone grow up to be
want to be like you?
One of the things I see in my clients
very,
very often,
and this is more characteristic of the
males and the females,
is that many of them will not allow the
cells to experience anger or aggression
or to express it because they have
tyrannical fathers,
you know,
and so one of the things they decided
when they were like four was,
I've never going to be like that.
It's like,
well,
that doesn't work out because you know
you need the capacity for anger and
hostility and aggression and all that.
You have to have that at hand and you
don't fix it.
By refusing to manifest.
All that does is cripple you because
you're missing half of your emotional
dynamism and a whole chunk of your
power.
Know we don't have that many sources of
You've got enthusiasm.
The answer,
good one,
curiosity,
interest,
appreciation for beauty.
You know,
anger is unbelievably useful,
tremendous reservoir of power.
You know,
and you don't want to suppress that.
You want to harness it so it's at hand
so that people don't mess with you
because they will.
People will push,
especially pushing people and if you
can,
well if you can't push back,
you're going to walk all over you.
They won't even notice,
you know,
because you'll just move and they'll,
they won't even notice that they pushed
you over so when you will go home,
you'll be all resentful and irritated
who brewed on it for a month and it's
like they didn't even have to say
anything at so.
And you know,
so the man I've seen often will refuse
themselves access to,
to anger in particular.
And then with women it's often the case
that they have a harder time getting
access to it because women are more
agreeable than men.
So it's harder for women to be,
you know,
it's hard for a woman even if she's
pretty damn tough to really contend with
the guidance.
Really difficult as guys who were really
disagreeable,
especially if they're physically
intimidating and super smart and those
people are very,
very difficult to deal with it,
you know,
because the cut you into pieces verbally
and they won't budge.
And so you have to really ratchet up
your preparation before you can
withstand that.
And you know,
a lot of women here who are going to be
dealing with in corporate environments
and dealing with people who are tough to
go in and get prepared for that.
And it's no joke.
There's some very,
very,
very broad card people up there.
And that's a good thing.
There's nothing would happen without,
you know,
there are forced to contend with.
So anyways,
the dragon of chaos,
roughly speaking,
differentiates itself.
And did these fundamental,
you could say personified elegance,
but for Sondra fight is the wrong idea
because you know,
usually when you think of something as
being personified,
do you think of it as being something
and then you act as if it's taken on
persona.
Find Quality,
you know,
so it's like a projection now.
I don't think that's how it works.
I think that we naturally experience the
world in the persona fight categories
and then we have to take them apart to
get the world,
you know,
look again at that differentiated world
out them.
So for example,
when you're a baby,
roughly speaking the world is your
mother,
and then as you differentiate the world,
it starts to turn into things that
aren't your mother,
but it isn't like you confuse the world
with your mother to begin with.
It's modern world to begin with.
And it's a perfectly reasonable way of
thinking about it.
I mean,
you're only this faith.
Your mother's really big and she's taken
3 billion years to build.
So you know,
that's a force of nature to contend
with.
And by thinking,
by conceptualizing that entity as the
world,
you've done a pretty good job of initial
modeling because think about this.
You're actually a reflection of the
world,
right?
You really are,
because you were shaped by the world in
your evolutionary development.
It's like,
here's the world hears you.
You're like,
you're a little reflection of the world
because the world has made you.
And so you embody it.
The world is the sort of place where
something like you can adjust to it.
That means you're a lot like the world.
And so if you start out with the
assumption that the world is a lot like
your mother is actually a pretty good
assumption,
it is pretty much like your mother and
she is a force of nature and so it's not
personification is first pass,
understand,
and then you know,
the father comes into it in one form or
another,
you know,
in a fractured for perhaps or a complete
form,
you know,
with the hope that you have a parent.
Do you have,
you hope you have an architectural
parents,
some sense who embodies that entire
dynamic range of what it means to have
that gender because then they're a
really good representative of the world.
Also,
most of the world that you're going to
interact with isn't stuff.
It's people.
So in so far as your mother and your
father or the world,
that's a really good model because
everyone you meet is going to be your
mother or your father roughly speaking.
So you know,
if they're very dynamic people and they
embodied the full range of human
possibility,
you know,
in so far as one person can do that,
then they're excellent models.
For what you're going to be interacting
with for the rest of your life and that
is what they should be,
right?
Because on average what you should do
for your children is be as much like the
world is you can be because that would
prepare them for the work so you
shouldn't be too nice because the world
isn't too nice and you shouldn't be too
harsh because then you'll just crush
them,
but you shouldn't be like making things
easy for them.
You know,
when you should be making things.
It's difficult for them as they can
possibly manage and it takes a real.
You really have to have a relationship
with a child will be able to do that
because you got to keep them in the zone
of proximal development and that to do
that you have to know what their life,
you know,
and so if they can carry five following
Monday,
he put another ounce on Tuesday and you
know,
that way they,
you,
you a lot.
It's the anti eatable approach.
You,
you encourage them to become strong and
independent.
Very hard on parents to do that.
Especially if they define their lives by
their children because they will want
the child to leave.
That's not a good thing because you
don't end up with the child.
You ended up with a crippled monster and
you know,
in the closet,
not good.
So.
Okay.
So anyways,
you know,
and the child obviously is there too.
There's the mother of the father and the
child whole situation,
that's the world.
And so that's what things break into the
first and I think our social cognitive
primate brain operates that way and then
if it operates that way and there seems
to be plenty of evidence that it does.
And then the next thing you might think
as well,
maybe that is the right thing.
So since our brain evolved and mirrors
reality,
that's perfectly reasonable way of
thinking about reality from Egypt on
great.
And from China on the left,
that's actually on the left.
That's actually Osiris and isis,
if I remember correct.
So that's so cool.
You know,
they emerge from the primordial serpent
out of chaos.
The predatory,
dangerous and promising chaos emerges.
The primary archetypal things.
Yeah.
No I don't.
And I can't give you much more
information about that,
although because a couple of students
sent it to me over different spans of
time.
So.
But I don't have the story at hand,
unfortunately.
I love this.
Okay.
It's now we're going to concentrate on
the fifth on the archetypes of the
feminine.
So this is femininity,
right?
This isn't a female a woman.
It's a class,
it's a category.
It's an architectural category.
So we're investigating the nature of the
feminine and the use of the feminine as
a mode of representing things.
Okay.
So this is a nice cap.
It's like done by know drug addled
hippies in the 19 sixties.
I think they lived in San Francisco.
Actually think they knew Robert crumb
because he was a.
He was an underground cartoonist and
fact I think crumb probably established
a little organization that gave this guy
who's named Ms Dot Gilbert Shelton.
His start in his career.
So he has these characters that are
three hippies and they're always
experimenting with drugs in one form or
another.
And they have this cat,
it's fat freddy's Cap.
And they kind of liked the cat and the
cap has its own adventures and this is
one of them.
So the hippies had just sold a bunch of
cocaine and they bought this little
estate in the country and so they're
bringing their cattle there and it's
never been in the country.
And it's pretty interesting.
I think it's a funny cartoon because
I've had cats and they hate it when you
move places,
you know,
because they're all comfortable where
they were.
And then you move to captain the new
place and it's like,
it's like the little rap that you just
put in the new cage,
that cat is not happy.
Maybe it will just sit there and cry
because they will do that,
you know?
But then they sort of loosen up and
eventually they sort of master the new
territory and it's very stressful for a
cap.
So dogs are much better at doing that
from,
for whatever reason.
Maybe it's because they're pack animals.
Okay.
Anyways,
the hippie takes the cat out,
shows them the country.
It'd be the cat's not that happy about
that.
So it goes into this crouch which
animals actually do when they explored
new territory.
So if you put a rat in a cage and it
starts to move around it hunches down,
you know,
sort of slinking through the undergrowth
basically so that nothing can see it.
So that's what cap will do.
And then the cat sniffs away,
which is what a capital do because
they're mostly old factory,
like most animals.
And then poof it encounters an anomaly
and that's already on edge.
So like an explorer exploring cat like
this would have,
it's for half popped up already because
it's funny.
It's preparing for what's lurking out
there in the unknown.
And then if anything just triggers it
over the edge.
You've seen this,
if you've ever gone behind the cap,
like wit to it,
if it's,
especially if it's someone startled
thing will just explode into for the
jump four feet in the air and then it's
very amusing,
you know,
so a little better off than the other
direction.
Take revenge on later.
So anyway,
is the cat encountered something that
doesn't understand and then runs up to
the adults.
And so the MP say the cap disappeared to
now and he says under the house and the
cat says Ukiah too,
if you'd smell what I did and then it
shows what it smells and it's a great
thing and it's like it's got duck feet
and it's got a like deer antlers and
it's got a whole face and it's got a
skunk tail and it's like you might say,
well that thing doesn't exist,
but then you might say,
wait a minute.
If you're going to derive a first pass
approximation of what the what's lurking
out there in the forest,
that's not a bad representation.
It's like it's alive.
It's got the properties of the skunk
going to and a wolf and all these things
in Melbourne made it into one thing.
Now it actually is what's waiting out
there in the bush.
Now as you exploring,
you're going to differentiate that into
sub categories,
but you don't.
You can't start your knowledge at a high
level of resolution.
You're going to start at a low level of
resolution.
You've got to come up with a low level
resolution model that's accurate but not
detailed.
And the reason you have to do that is
because you bloody well better do it
fast because if you don't,
you're going to be sitting around and
thinking,
well,
are you a deer,
a wolf or a Fox?
And the next answer to that is,
I'm the thing that eight,
you know,
so it's not a good,
it's not a good approach.
You want to get quick and dirty.
And that's why kids,
I think that's why kids imagine monsters
all the time in the dark.
It's like there aren't monsters,
well not in that particular gardens,
but the kid is not that stupid.
It's wired up,
knows what's out there in the dark and
it's not good.
And so it takes a lot of calming to make
a chart,
especially because we have kids sleep in
your own bedroom.
Like that's not natural for kids.
I know what I'm saying.
That is what should happen.
But as an evolutionary know,
I think it does encourage you to
dependents and all that.
He at the cost of some trauma.
But you know,
you can perfectly well imagine that
collective humans,
150,000
years ago stayed in a pretty type heat
when they were sleeping because that's a
lot safer,
especially if they're,
if you're little and delicious and
edible.
So.
So I love the cartoon because it's also
a really useful illustration about how
fantasy,
you know,
how a fantasy operates automatically and
regenerate these generic low resolution
categories.
All right,
so now here is,
this is Kelly.
She's a Hindu goddess.
And so you might say,
well,
did people invent gods?
I think that's a very weird question
because the answer is yes.
And NASA results will know because you
could also just as easily say that God's
people.
It depends on how you look at anyways,
you know,
if you think about it from a Marxist
perspective or Friday and perspective or
from a scientific perspective and those
perspective that tend to be very
destructive to religious thinking.
You're basically,
you've got to think,
okay,
well the image is there to,
to protect you against death,
anxiety or,
and that it's a substitute father.
That's the Freud defined again,
basically,
or that their religion was constructed
to aid in abet.
Those are in those who are empowered to
keep all the peasants and the Lo life's
under control by,
you know,
like promising them happy ever after if
they behave or that it's just a
primitive scientific theory that should
be superseded now that we have more
knowledge.
Those are the alternative hypotheses.
Okay,
well let's look at this image.
So this is Kelly and she's a destroyer.
Devour that doesn't mean she's bad by
the way.
It means something to contend with.
She's like the tmf.
So I couldn't take her apart so that you
can see her because you can't,
unless you happen to know what this
means because of your culture and even
then you might not be able to see it.
So let's figure it out.
Now she has eight ladies.
Why?
What has eight legs expire?
How do you all feel about spiders?
Right?
And the reason you feel like that is
because you have these little spider
detectors on your skin.
Those are basically cares.
And when the spider crawls along in the
spider detectors,
you get this creepy feeling and that's
you basically shaking your skin to get
rid of the damn spider course.
You can't do that anymore because you're
not a horse,
you know,
so you just kind of have this digital
feeling like that.
And spider can give you a good chomping,
you know?
And so sometimes that's actually
poisonous and that's not so good.
But also a spiker is an interesting
thing from a conceptual perspective
because it spins a web and the web
catches things that aren't paying
attention.
And then the thing that isn't paying
attention gets wrapped up in this
spider's Web and then it gets sucked
dry.
So that's a spider.
Okay.
So she's a spider now.
Spiders are pretty cool too because they
can spin webs,
you know.
And that's the web of faith by the way.
That's the way with faith.
Um,
so that's one thing.
She's a,
she's a spider and then,
well she's in this web,
but the web has made other fire that's
fire.
And then inside the fire,
those are skulls.
So she's a spider that sits in a web of
fire and skulls,
so believe me,
if you saw a spider like that,
you'd be looking at it.
You might screen first and maybe he
would run away,
but then you'd come back and look at it.
It's like,
oh look,
I found a spider,
a web of fire itself.
I'm happy,
very attractive to you.
You probably wouldn't be able to forget
about it.
And you know,
that's one thing about Kelly.
She's the bunch of things that you
bloody well cannot forget about.
And so you could actually even say she's
a model of all those things that you can
forget about.
And then you could say,
well,
she's an attempt tomorrow.
All those things you can't forget about.
And you might say,
well why would you want to model those
things?
Well it's because you bloody well better
remember those things or you're not
going to stay alive.
And then you might ask,
what should you be dealing with?
The things that you shouldn't forget
about one by one fires say or,
or,
or skeletons.
Should you be dealing with that one on
one or spiders or snakes or should you
be dealing with that as a category?
Right?
That's the thing about human beings is
we like to deal with things as
categories because that way you could
solve a whole bunch of problems at the
same time.
You know,
so you might say you do this all the
time.
You don't.
If you go on log on online and you look
at people who are having one advice
about relationships,
they want advice about relationships and
you think,
well really what they want is to figure
out how to deal with this female or this
mail,
but they don't ask that question.
They ask,
how can I improve my relationships?
Which is that they're trying to solve
the problem of how to relate to all the
set of all potential relationships right
now because maybe that's better
information than exactly what to do
about this particular male or female at
this particular point in time.
Now,
often it isn't,
but you can understand why people push
for that.
It's like,
why not get the general answer?
If you can,
then you solve the whole class of
problems.
Okay,
so what's the class of problems here?
The class of problems here is the class
of problems.
It's how do you conceptualize the class
of problems?
It's a brilliant.
That's such a brilliant question.
You know,
for,
for.
I mean maybe you can't.
Maybe there's no commonality between all
of those things that constitute a
problem,
but by the same token,
maybe there is.
Well this is an attempt to do that.
Okay.
So what else about the Kelly?
She's got a sword for hair's on fire.
She also has a headband of skulls now
people don't like smells very much,
you know,
they creep us out and there's good
reason for that because all things
considered,
you should probably avoid places where
there are a lot of sculpture because
it's easy to infer from that that a lot
of people like you died there and that
might be because there's something
around that it's going to kill you just
like it killed all those other things or
there's some illness or whatever.
It's like get the hell out of there.
So even chimps don't like chip hands and
they don't like it.
Mobile chip bodies.
So you know,
a scuffle for us it's like well you can
see it's death itself,
you know,
and it is that,
but it's an architect will assemble and
you don't get accustomed to skull very,
very hard.
So just got skulls everywhere.
Well sometimes she has tons of a tire
but she doesn't think this particular
representation.
But sometimes she does.
And that's the predatory element.
And the tiger,
that's a pretty fascinating thing,
right?
Because it's like 12 feet long,
five feet high and you know,
it's a major piece of engineering back
and probably it will eat you.
So to put the timer is counting on.
County also indicates that she's
representative of those terrible awe,
inspiring predatory things that lurk in
the forest.
Of course this is an Indian
representation.
She often has this snake around her
waist and usually it's a Cobra Cobra.
Is there another thing that people find
absolutely fascinating like fire and
then.
But not in this situation,
what she has wrapped around her instead
of her intestines.
And you see how our bellies hall,
she just gave birth to that unfortunate
character that she happened to be
standing on and his intestines that
she's eating right now.
I fail to see how this symbol can
protect you from death anxiety,
you know,
quite the contrary.
It seems to me to be something that
would seriously evoke it,
you know,
and there's no patriarchal protection
here and I can't see how anybody could
use this to oppress the peasants.
You know,
maybe they could scare them with it,
but that isn't actually how Kelly is
used.
So I don't think that that's a useful
way of thinking about it at all.
Now,
interestingly enough,
Kelly is something you made sacrifices
to now that's cool.
And because it's weird,
people have had a hard time to figure it
out.
The whole idea of sacrifice.
So there was this guy who was a
journalist in the 19 sixties and he
wrote a book,
his name was Arthur Kessler.
He wrote a book called the ghost in the
machine,
which is a book of consciousness.
And one of the things he pointed out was
that the Motif of sacrifice seemed to be
architectural,
it was universal,
it was happening everywhere.
And one of the side effects of that was
human sacrifice.
Go onto row,
upset you can sacrifice a couple of
slaves or captures or children because
the Carthaginians used to do that all
the time,
their own children.
And they have them smile before they
killed them.
So it was brutal room.
But the Carthaginians they would commit
suicide at the drop of a hat because
their basic idea was if you screwed up
while you're wrong,
time to kill yourself,
there's no hope for you.
So it's very common idea.
And the Japanese still practiced that
before World War Two as well.
It's like,
so.
So anyways,
so the whole idea of sacrifice pretty
damn dark,
you know,
and,
and Kessler regarded it as evidence that
the human race was basically insane,
like fundamental,
biological manner that was not fixable.
So it was like the ultimate in original
sin and the theorizing,
you know,
when that was written,
when everybody was all shorted out about
the fact that we are going to blow
ourselves up with nuclear weapons.
And so the idea that humans were
basically insane,
which is not a bad theory,
you know,
you could even say we're,
we've been driven insane by the nature
of being anyways.
You make sacrifices to kill it.
They're often blood sacrifices.
Now that's kind of interesting because
one of the things that you might notice
about what Kelly represent,
which you might say is the predatory,
like almost diabolical site of nature.
You know,
the part of nature that's really working
hard at doing un is that it does seem to
thrive on blood.
And so there's an idea here which is if
you give the damn thing what it wants,
maybe it will leave you alone.
But there's more sophisticated idea
right beneath that.
Because what happens if you sacrifice to
Kelly because she turns into her office
and her opposite is,
well,
it's the opposite of this.
It's benevolent nature.
It's the kind of nature that that
environmentalists believe it,
you know,
it's like nature as French
impressionists landscape.
It's not mosquito mosquitoes and Guinea
worms and cancer and crocodiles and
gangrene.
It's,
you know,
it's,
it's a sunny day in that old growth
forest where you know,
Disney dear,
constantly around smiling at you.
You know,
and that's nature too because nature is
what gibbs and if you use the feminine,
the feminine symbolism,
I mean your mother is certainly someone
who can be an absolutely horrific forest
and that often happens to infants,
but by the same token,
chief,
the bearer of everything that pulls you
into life,
you know,
and her,
her contact with you or her physical
contact or ability to play with you.
The fact that she looks at you,
the fact that she feeds you directly
from her body.
It's like that's the whole opposite of
Kali,
the destroyer,
and they're both elements of the
feminine.
And part of the reason I think that it's
the feminine per se that came to
represent the destructive element of
nature as well as the positive element
is that men experience women in many
ways.
As the disruptive element of the
feminine,
because men are always been rejected by
women and women are nature because
nature is what selects you to reproduce,
and so the answer for most women to most
men is you're a nice enough guy,
but there's no way your genes should
propagate themselves into the future,
you know,
and that's as harsh a judgment as could
possibly be rendered.
If you watch chrome,
for example,
which I recommend it because it's full
of great mother's symbolism is he's
being described himself as someone who
is so much of a loser.
He's not even in the dominance
hierarchy,
you know,
he's not at the bottom,
he's outside,
you know,
so he described himself as someone for
it was,
especially him and his older brother,
it was virtually impossible for there to
even conceive of the idea that they
might ask a girl in high school.
It wasn't that they would get refused.
It was that it was inconceivable that
they could even do it.
That's where they were in the dominance
arc.
So of course from and who has a mother
to go with it,
you know,
all his females are like these extremely
physically powerful bird headed
goddesses,
more or less,
and he construed themselves with this
little word thing that's sort of
cowering at their feet and it's deeply
embedded and to wonder,
given his circumstances,
it's no wonder he actually did a
remarkable job of,
of developing himself in a,
in a,
in a productive manner,
I think given what he had to go against.
But anyways,
yeah,
he is.
You sacrificed to Kelby and you bring
forth its opposite.
Now it's like I was once I thought,
I thought I understood,
I thought that I had come to understand
the idea of sacrifice.
I think I figured this out about 15
years ago and it just blew up.
Blew me over when I figured it out
because it had always been viewed either
as kind of an empath phenomenon or
something that's pathological,
but it's not.
It's the most remarkable.
It's one of the most remarkable
conceptual discoveries that human race
has ever made because what it meant was
we started to figure out that if you
gave something,
what it wanted,
if you gave something something of
value,
then you can turn it into something that
might be beneficial to you.
So it's the,
it's,
it's the common towns of delayed
gratification.
Delayed gratification is a sacrifice.
So you know the,
the,
the marshmallow experiment,
right?
Okay.
So you get these little kids,
you're tortured,
you say,
hey,
you like marshmallows.
It's like,
yeah,
I know you.
Okay?
So here's the advice of the.
Now if you don't eat those marshmallows,
you get to have more marshmallows.
And so then you leave.
And some of the kids eat parched,
Alex,
right?
And you got to admit those kids.
There's something about them to get the
damn marshmallows,
you know?
So if there was an earthquake,
right,
then those kids would have one.
Okay?
So that's something to think about
because delayed gratification is not
always the right answer.
The environment has to be stable enough
so that the probability that you will
get what you've delayed for is high,
and so if you're living in sheer chaos,
you're a fool to delay gratification.
It's like eat the damn marshmallow now
so,
so it's not like delayed gratification
is the solution for everything.
It's not.
Sometimes it's the solution.
So what do you do?
You make the sacrifice now and the idea
is it will pay off in the future so that
you think about that in architectural
forms.
That means that you forego something of
value.
Now it's a sacrifice you let go of it
and the deal is if you let go of it,
better things will happen to you in the
future and you know,
no other animal has figured that out.
Well,
squirrels maybe because they store
knocks,
but I don't really believe that they.
I think it's fundamentally an instinct.
You know what I mean?
I don't think they generalize from that
idea.
They do act it out,
but I don't think they generalize from
it.
They haven't turned it into a concept.
And so the concept here is the world is
constituted such that it hasn't
tremendously destructive element,
but if you can barter with that
properly,
then you can flip it over into part of
it.
That's positive group will reveal
itself.
That's bloody brilliant.
It's unbelievably brilliant.
And there's even another element to it
because let's say that all your,
all you been getting from reality for
awhile is Kelly.
It's all spiders and snakes and fires
and skull.
You know what's and and things that want
to eat you.
You might think why.
One answer is,
well,
that's just what it's like,
but then that's a problem because that's
not just what it's like.
You know that the opposite is there.
And you might say,
well where,
where the hell is that?
Like why is it hard to get space for me?
And one answer is I reality is cannot be
contentedly that's one ass.
But that's like you're depressed and
hopeless like you're done.
Here's another answer.
You might be doing something wrong and
then you might think,
well what would it mean to be doing
something wrong?
And then we might say,
maybe you're hanging onto something you
value a little too tightly,
maybe one of your axiomatic
presuppositions,
like the thing that's at the top of your
damn value structure is actually
sufficiently outdated or pathological
such that if you hold onto it all,
you're going to get his rounds and
misery.
So maybe you have to let it go.
That's a sacrifice.
And so maybe that's why the rule is when
you're making sacrifices to Kelly,
you don't sacrifice the low quality
junk.
You sacrifice the stuff that you were
attached to you because if things aren't
going right,
it could be that it's because you're
attached to the wrong things.
Now that's interesting.
That's starting to get very interesting
because that means that people are
starting to think maybe my attitude has
something to do,
something I can change.
Like maybe it's not just the factual
nature of the external world.
It's something I can contend with and
dance with.
And maybe if I readjusted my moral
Schema,
the profitability is kind of low that
Kelly will be there all the time and
it'll be pretty high that her positive
counterparts shows up.
So then the question might be how do we
set,
make the sacrifices that are necessary
to organize our schema of interpretation
in behavior such that when we
implemented in the world,
reality shines since positive face on us
in order it's negative face.
And like that's incredibly complicated
problems,
right?
I mean that's,
that's problem.
Human beings being trying to figure out
at animals for that kind of forever,
you know,
it wasn't until they were human beings
that you started to get some conceptual
representation.
But then the other thing too is you guys
are all doing that.
You haven't been back going with nature
and the fattiest
made some sacrifices right now.
Or maybe your parents are making
sacrifices on your behalf and what's the
bed?
The bed is.
It will be worth it.
But what does that mean?
It means that if you make the proper
sacrifices,
you discipline yourself.
You don't,
you're not to dilute with your
resources.
You pay attention and you wait.
Your life will be better.
That's pretty cool because it might be
true and if it's true,
then none of this is illusion or
delusion.
It's just low resolution.
First pass representation that smart and
so you know from a Piagetian
perspective,
well,
what do you do before you understand
something,
act it out.
And so the people that were making
sacrifices,
they're acting out this idea.
Do they know the idea is what you mean
by?
No,
no,
you're acting it out.
They're dramatically representing you.
Is that knowledge or it's a form of
knowledge?
Is it the kind of abstract knowledge
that we're talking about right now?
No,
but it's the immediate precursor to that
you don't get from the phenomena to the
articulation without running it through
some bodily representations and some
drama and this is so damn complicated
that,
you know,
you probably couldn't get to it until
you had civilizations that were pretty
damn good.
And lots of people thinking about this
all the time,
you know,
so the person who came up with this,
they would have experienced it as
religious revelation.
It's like what's the nature of reality?
You get this image,
you know,
some of this multi armed goddess and
it's inflamed.
It's in a way up and it's like
terrifying.
It's terrifying you.
You're gripped by it and you make a
representation and part of the reason
you worship it is because the bloody
thing is,
is you when its grip and no wonder
because there's an idea behind that is
so powerful that you shouldn't be
gripped by it.
You should be unable to forget it
because it's,
it's an absolute,
it's a stellar stroke of genius.
It's a real revelation and it sets the
whole human race on the path to making
the proper sacrifices so that the fire
and the bugs and the insects and the
snakes and the Tigers stay the hell away
and a good thing.
It's a good thing.
And then maybe now and then you know,
the world's can so that it's beneficial
to us.
I'm not sure if this would be greatest
moment,
but um,
I asked a question before my shirt.
You got to it last.
Did you can just directly stating when
you think of as an architect when you
used the word
well that's
good.
That's a good question.
This is an archetype,
but your behavioral reactions to that
could also the architect.
So I would say it's the expression of
something that's at the foundation of
knowledge,
so it's like an innate axiom of
representation and behave and it's
archetypes that make us human rather
than lines or ants.
We have human architects and those are
the things that we can dispense.
They're built into us like,
well,
jealousy would be an architect for
example.
It's an archetypal pattern,
hunger,
thirst,
all of these things that are common to
everyone,
but there are more.
They're more conceptual archives to,
to like,
like things,
you know,
it's a,
it's a fuzzy word,
but it,
it,
it has to do with the element of
idiation and action that are not merely
culturally constructed.
Let's say.
Is it something like I'm in jeans,
something like there has to be a sub
straight,
but then it also has triggered or
activated by something or is it just
kind of all over again?
Well,
that's a good question.
That's a good question.
Um,
I,
I don't,
I think the,
I think I can answer that in some sense
by analogy.
John would not be able to learn language
unless they had the archetype of
language at hand,
right?
Does it have to be triggered?
Twins sometimes come up with their own
language,
identical twins,
so they'll just create a life,
you know,
and so there's a pretty powerful
language creating capacity,
but generally speaking,
yes,
it's triggered because you're thrown
into an environment where,
which is the norm,
but you can throw a chip in there and
that's not going to work.
Now what it is that makes people,
they are able to generate languages
that's complicated because partly it's,
you have the right mouth,
you have the right timing,
you have the right throat,
you know,
and then you have the right brain,
whatever the hell that means.
And we don't,
we don't exactly know what any of those
things mean.
So we use the word archetype to kind of
cover rate in roots in some sense.
Does the human psychological element of
archetypes in your views change?
Um,
change qualitatively when human beings
are having widespread access to board
presentations?
Hopefully.
Because otherwise it wouldn't be any.
There wouldn't be any utility in
developing your representations.
Mean I,
so I think the question you're asking in
some senses is representation useful and
the answer is so far so good,
you know,
useful,
but just that,
like the thing itself,
once represented,
does that representation and now filter
back in and then change this thing that
started out.
So I would say it doesn't happen all
sorts of ways.
So for example,
in some ways the dominance hierarchy is
a way that animals organize themselves
in an environment,
but if they do that long enough it
becomes the environment,
right?
Because once it's,
once the adaptation is being there for
100 million years,
it's no longer an outpatient.
It's part of the environment.
So there's loops,
causal loops happening everywhere.
So yeah,
the representation changes the
archetype.
God only knows how.
And over what period of time.
Yes,
yes,
there is a relationship,
but I don't know enough about Hinduism
to tell you what it is.
So you know,
I'm not,
I'm not an expert on Hinduism,
that's for sure.
It's very complicated religious system,
you know,
but you know,
I do know that these sub dailies,
so to speak,
are manifestations of the ultimate
reality when there's many,
there's some utility in that because
it's,
it's monotheistic at one level of
analysis and polytheistic and another,
it makes it easier,
you know,
you could think about these as bridges
between the human and the absolute
divine,
the absolute divine so damn abstract and
distant that it's hard to have any
relationship with it.
You need intermediary structures and the
saints are like that.
Catholicism,
you know,
because they're sort of God's roughly
speaking,
but they're sort of human.
So when you could kind of understand
them and their fractionated out and so
the only representative of the day,
you know,
so they're not the whole thing all at
once,
which is a bit much to contend with.
So,
so you think having diverse vocabulary
of health people,
I don't know if it helps it.
Say that again.
Um,
it helps them differentiated now.
Okay.
And articulate.
So now we want to think about what that
means.
Okay.
So I think I've told you before,
I've seen children that haven't been
played up with enough,
so maybe they're five or six and they're
kind of,
they're like little Frankenstein,
you know,
you're kind of uninformed and kind of
cloudy and clueless and they bump into
things like other kids,
you know,
and so they're,
they're not articulated well.
And so the other kids usually won't play
with them because they're sort of that a
three year old level of development when
they should be at a six year old devil
of development.
Just puts the other kids off,
you know,
they find it creepy and there's reasons
for that that I won't go into.
But those kids aren't differentiated,
you know,
they haven't got the extremely high
level movements down.
And so as you articulate an archetype
and it diversifies,
you become more adapted to multiple
places.
So that's what you want to do.
You want to take the damn archetype and
differentiated like mad because for
example,
when you're looking at a woman,
you don't want to see only the
archetype.
First of all,
you'd be on your knees if that happened.
Believe me,
there's lots of men like that.
They're really are.
It's animal possession.
It's way more common than you think.
I see this with male clients all the
time.
If they're attracted to a woman,
her mere presence is so god damn
overwhelming that it just ties.
They're talking about the naughts and
what's happening is they're not seeing
the individual.
You're seeing the archetype and
archetype is life is just too much.
Now,
what's interesting is the archetype does
shine through the woman.
It's real,
but the individual part is real too.
Unless the guy is capable of
differentiating the archetype into that
actual woman to woman won't have
anything to do with him or maybe she'll
play with them like a spider plays with
the fly and it serves them right too.
But,
but so you have to have both,
you know?
And so that's partly why.
Remember Sleeping Beauty,
the Disney movie,
you know how the,
the hero is put into a castle by the
evil queen,
right?
And then sleeping beauty is sleeping.
And so then he has to fight his way
through this architectural
representation,
which actually transforms itself into
the dragon of chaos.
He has to fight his way all through all
of that before it can actually get to
the real woman.
And that's exactly what happens with men
as they develop poor,
failed to develop is the first thing to
the degree that they're immature.
All they see is the archetype,
and they're very inferior in
relationship to the archetype because
unless they were Christ,
so to speak,
you know they're going to be at.
You're going to be on their needs.
And so to contend with,
the archetype means first of all,
to elevate the mail because as he
contends with it,
he develops,
right?
But at it also means to,
to to place the two equality.
And then the archetype turns into the
individual woman.
Now that's a big sacrifice because you
know,
hypothetically,
you rather have sleeping beauty that
pretend princess in some actual woman
with all her trouble.
But the problem is there isn't sleeping
beauty that pretending princess.
There's just the real woman.
And you see that with Peter Pan to the
story.
Because he's got tinker bell,
that's fine,
except for Tinkerbell to ferry and they
don't exist,
so he could have wendy if he would grow
up,
but he doesn't want to grow up,
so he's not going to get Wendy's just
been in state king of the bloody lost
boys and that will be the end of that.
So,
so it's differentiation of architects
and that's what you're doing as you
develop across time.
Now there's a book called the origins
and history of consciousness,
which was written by a guy named Eric
normand and it's a book that's very much
like maps are being because I believe
that NASA meeting has been written four
times.
Um,
it's symbols of transformation and
growth that it's origins and history of
consciousness.
Eric Norman,
who was a student of young,
wrote that and it's also Becker's denial
of death and it's because you know,
when there's elements and heidegger are
very similar because all that's all
working on the same problem.
But one of the things that's lovely
about knowing that he's very smart about
this,
he describes the acquisition of
knowledge as the differentiation of the
archetypes.
And that's brilliant.
It's right,
it's like the thing itself is a unified
whole that sort of the divine ground of
reality.
Then it fragments into the first three
layers,
masculine,
feminine and Chai,
and then that fragments and hopefully
what it does is fragments right down to
the level of individuals so that when
you're interacting with someone,
you're interacting to their with their
individual expression of the archetypal
reality because then you're actually
interacting with the person and that'll
get you a lot farther in any kind of
relationship than being blown over by
the architect project or would it be.
I don't think you project them.
It's not like you have a choice.
It's.
That's how you see the world.
It's the default because it projection
implies that you could be doing
something else.
It's like everything you see is an
archetype.
Although some of them are differentiated
and they can become extremely
differentiated in so far as you know,
come to know a person,
you know,
if you're reading I to get differentiate
the damn thing down to the level of
individual recognition and you're so
skilled at that,
but the archetypal reality reestablishes
itself and then you get to have your
cake and eat it too.
Okay.
So one of the things that you can
conceptualize marriage,
because marriage is a human universal
vitally something to think about.
You know,
so it looks like it's built into us
pretty hard at a biological level.
So there's variations obviously and
there's the,
there are certain attractions and
believe me,
especially for men,
but all things considered,
no matter where you looked in the world,
there's generally an attempt by the
culture to st a man that woman pair now
young was trying to figure out why the
hell that would be it.
I mean there's the biological necessity.
Obviously you've gotten raised kids
somehow and there shouldn't just be one
of you,
but you don't want to just reduce
everything down to the,
you know,
to the level of two rats living
together,
even though that's an important level
and know.
He said that one of the things that's
really useful about evolve is that you
can't run away from the damn thing if
it's an actual viable.
So what you're supposed to do when you
marry someone is you say,
look,
I'm stuck with you and we're going to
bet on this because we only get five
shots at it anyways,
and you know,
you're the least awful person I've come
across and so let's tie ourselves
together so we cannot escape and see
what happens.
And so then you think if you take that
seriously,
you think,
oh my God,
I'm stuck with this damn person for the
rest of my life.
Also.
Then when,
if you really can't escape,
you think,
well,
keep better,
build something out of this because
we're stuck in it.
And so you don't conceptualize the
marriage as an all chemical containers,
and he derived this from the studies on
alchemy where two opposite substances
were placed together in a container they
could not escape from and then exposed
to heat and the heat,
the relationship obviously,
and all the emotions,
but the relationship generates,
they're exposed to heat and they can't
get out of the damn container.
What happens?
Well,
there's a transmutation.
Transmutation is a consequence of the
exchange of information.
So,
and we know this works at a biological
level,
right?
So part of the reason that there is sex
is because if we split your DNA down the
middle and that it's something that's
exactly to say wherever there is a
weakness,
the two weaknesses are going to combine
and you're going to end up with
offspring.
They're all mocked up.
Now that's basically a consequence of
inbreeding.
So what you want to do is you want to
take your applaud genetic substance,
which is,
you know,
99 point nine percent good.
And someone else's blog,
genetic substances snap them together
and hope like hell that the errors don't
match up.
And they probably won't.
And so that's what you're doing in a
relationship.
It's like,
you know,
you're screwing somebody,
you cap ex and so is the other person.
Then.
So when you slap those two things
together and you hope that I'll of that
you build in totality.
Okay?
And that starts the information flow
moving.
So then the question is what would you
do if the information flow was a
curator?
What,
what happened to you?
So let's say you're 20 percent work,
which,
which is taste pretty good and your
partner's 20 percent more to,
but our,
luckily you're warps.
Don't match up what that means.
If you listen to each other over a long
enough period of time,
if you really communicated,
then you wouldn't be warped anymore and
neither would the other person.
And then you'd have the archetypal
situation as well as the individual
situation.
Right?
You see what I mean?
Because you both have been elevated up
to the point where you're not full of
holes anymore.
And you think,
well that's part of the purpose in so
far as there's this psychological and
spiritual function of marriage.
That's it.
And so you can,
you can have freedom.
You could say,
well this is a,
not that we can untie,
but the problem with that is you don't
have to contend with the person then.
No,
you don't get.
You don't have to take it seriously.
You don't have to take it as if it's
life and death.
But the problem is it is,
it is life and death.
It is.
Maybe you can have another shot at it.
I don't see why you think you'll do
better the second time because all the
evidence suggests that you won't.
The divorce rate higher for second
marriages.
So like you know,
the thing about being tied to someone
who isn't you is that they're not.
You have something to tell you if you
listen.
And so then you start with the flawed
individual and if you're paying yourself
against each other enough,
what you hope is that you both develop
and you shared your excess baggage along
the way.
And that can happen.
You know,
it's a good thing if it happens.
You live longer,
you have a better life,
the situation for your children.
It's like everybody wins in that
situation.
Okay,
let's.
You're all getting restless,
so let's stop and come back and come
back in 10 minutes.